okay so let's get started
so it's this afternoon speakers Massimo
Banzi Ani thank you very much for having
me very happy to be here today I'm going
to present data by Anthony lien he was a
graduate student in my lab now postdoc
in in at UCSF and he did some truly
outstanding yet unpublished work that
I'm going to present to you today
so moving stimuli are very salient
stimuli very important data logically
speaking if I there are animals that
only Sistema see if it's moving a
signature to moving stimulus was first
reported an actual physiological
signature was first reported about 60
years ago in the brain by Google and
diesel who noticed that neurons in
primary visual cortex of cats not only
responded to edges of luminance that had
an orientation but also could
preferentially respond in that edge of
luminance would move in one direction a
direction which is perpendicular to the
main axis of the stimulus right but not
to the other eye this is a unoriented
edge this is electrophysiological
recording extracellular recording from
the oscilloscope here you see spikes in
response to this edge moving in this
direction right but much fewer much less
activity from this neuron and that same
edge move in the opposite direction so
the mechanisms the mechanisms underlying
the underlying direction selectivity in
the cortex have been speculated a lot
upon but but we're still very still no
conclusive accepted mechanisms for how
for how it is it emerges for for how it
appears models that suggest that
the direction selectivity in cortex
emerges through into a cortical circuit
right now other models also supported by
quite some literature data suggests that
Direction selectivity emerges at the
convergence of teramo cortical inputs
right and then more more recently work
mainly spearheaded by by our
understanding of direction selectivity
in the retina of the mouse suggest that
maybe Direction selectivity in cortex is
at least in large part simply inherited
right from early stages of visual
processing okay I would like to address
which mechanism may actually occur in
the visual cortex of the mouse and I'm
going to do this first by focusing right
on the dynamic input onto onto cortical
neurons so when we do the approach is
going to be
- those mics are anesthetized they're in
in front of a monitor and we're going to
perform a wholesale recording from layer
four neuron to source a recording will
be either in current clamp or in voltage
now if you do a current clamp holds the
recording from a layer four neuron and
you present the drifting greetings as a
visual stimulus and you present those
ratings in various orientations within
various direction you can see that in
this particular case
Noorie entered grating drifting towards
11:00 o'clock produce robust firing in
this particular neuron right while the
same grating with a different
orientation different direction produce
much less firing and so you can explore
this parameter space and end up with a
poor approach that tells you which one
is the preferred so the preferred
orientation of the grating right and in
fact that tells you also whether what
the preferred direction of the grating
in this case our grating and that looks
like this and that that drifts towards
towards 11:00 o'clock and this is a
representation of heat in terms of a
linear plot where you plot the spiking
of the neuron versus the direction of
the stimulus and you see these marks
directions
activity now in order to understand how
those tuning properties of the neuron
occur we need we want to we want to
isolate the Tolima key input and see
what properties are already present at
the Ptolemaic input and in order to do
this we need to be able to isolate the
excitation that originates from the
thalamus from the excitation that layer
for neuron received from other cortical
neuron in particular from other layer
four called cortical neuron in fact the
vast majority of excitatory inputs that
earlier for neuron received is from
other cortical neuron and only about 10%
originates from the thalamus so in order
to isolate the Ptolemaic input electro
physiologically we harness the power of
inhibition in the cortex and we express
the optogenetic actuators
channelrhodopsin selectively in
inhibitory neuron and by illuminating
the surface of the cortex with blue
light we can activate to the neuron and
essentially silence every single path
spike throughout the depths of the
cortex in a pyramidal neuron thereby
isolating the thalamic input onto the
neuron we are recording from right and
so this is the protocol that I'm going
to use quite a bit for the rest of the
talk so before we go into the details of
Direction selectivity I need to spend a
few words on orientation selectivity and
on the receptive field structure of the
Ptolemaic input or two cortical neuron
and the reason why i first need to go on
to orientation selectivity will become
clear as we discussed directions
selectivity so what is the receptive
field structure of the Ptolemaic input
onto a cortical neuron and we explore
this by presenting sparse noise more or
less randomly flashing little square of
increases or decreases in luminance onto
a gray monitor while recording from a
layer four neuron in a wholesale voltage
clamp and silencing visual cortex in
what you observe if you presenter to
stimuli in a matrix of eight by eight
onto your monitor each square has about
the size of five and five degrees is
that the vast majority of the monitor
doesn't produce any excitatory current
now this is voltage clamp so an
excitatory current is a downward
deflection but for when the black square
this is this is the response to black
square appears here in this portion of
the monitor right more or less at the
center may be shifted slightly towards
the right that's the that's that's the
the place where when you present a black
square you generate thalamic currents
writing this particular new you could do
the same with white squares right and
what you observe is that and that the
the spatial distribution of those white
squares on the monitor necessary to
evoke an excitatory current on the
recording urine overlaps the one of of
black squares and and this is our
population average there is a large
overlap but they are not exactly
centered and this is quite important
their peak are separated on averages by
five degrees a profile cut through the
the axis that connects the two Centers
of those receptive field you can see
that there is indeed the separation and
the peak and the separation of the peak
first of all this distribution of
receptive field reminds what a reading a
lot so the spread about twenty years ago
and it's very important to provide the
neuron with the response property to the
luminance address and intuitively this
can be shown here if you have a ceramic
receptive field structure in which you
have an overlapping on-and-off sub
region which are however
separated by a few degree the best
possible stimulus right to activate that
Kalama kin put is a stimulus in which a
dark bar overlaps with the peak of the
off receptive field and a white bar
overlap with the peak of the on
receptive field right and this is going
to create a good strong thalamic
excitation on the other hand if that
gratings shift just
a little bit such at the black bar
overlap with the peak of the on
receptive field and the white bar with a
peak of the off receptive field this is
clearly a soo bahk demon stimulus and is
going to produce a minimum amount of
excitation imagine not this greeting
drifting we are going to have this
amplitude modulation of the thalamic
response from a strong Ptolemaic
response to a weak diameter serratus
muscles strong tonics as water with a
mixer strong
we call this modulation f1 modulation
because it contains the periodicity main
periodicity of the grating as it passes
in front of the receptive field of the
neuron you are recording right clearly
if you present a grating which has an
orthogonal reinfection right now you
never will have a pattern which
perfectly activates the receptive field
of the neuron either one that completely
Tsubaki money activated and so your f1
modulation is going to be you're going
to have essentially as the great grating
drift an ongoing average activation of
your effective field which is neither
maxima or minima and so the f1
modulation is going to be much less
pronounced right and this leads to the
fact that if you look at the f1
modulation of this dynamic current right
adrift grating drifts in front of the
receptive field of the neuron you have
essentially an orientation tuning of
this f1 modulation and this can be
directly tested experimentally we first
we can first by using those two squares
determine the special structure of the
receptive field right for that
particular neuron and this shows that
there is enough region here and unknown
region here and this axis right which
connects the peak of the on and the peak
of the off should define right should be
perpendicular to the orientation the
preferred orientation of a grating and
this is indeed the case because if we
then keep that neuron now instead of
presenting square flashes we start
presenting grating drifting in various
operating grating of various
orientations anything with different
direction right you indeed see that
there is a very close match between the
orientation and our
action of the grating that produces the
maximal f1 modulation and the prediction
simply based on the organization of on
and off sub region mapped through this
sparse noise right and this is this is
the the summary for for a number of such
experiment so the owner of separation
right of the receptive field predicts
very well the preferred orientation of a
stimulus for the f1 modulation of
dynamic excitation alright so
orientation tuning derive from this
separation on a non breath off receptive
field in in cortical neuron but what
determines direction selectivity how
come that given a specific orientation
of a stimulus when that grating drift in
one direction the neuron responds very
strongly
well when the grating adrift in the
other direction the neuron respond much
less so again let's look at them at at
what happens with the thalamic input so
this is this is a layer for neuron
recorded in current clamp this is for
disease this is a very clear example of
directionally selective neuron it
responds well to vertical grating but in
particular it was vertical grating or
drifting to the right right you see the
oscillation of the membrane potential
and a lot of spikes while if that
grating drifts to the left right the
response is much weaker a classical
directionally selective neuron now lets
a voltage clamp that neuron and silence
visual cortex right in order to isolate
the thalamic input as I showed before
and this is the dynamic response right
to a grating to the same grating
drifting to the right and this is a
cycle average right of this f1
modulation I was telling you about and
now here what you have is the same
isolate atomic input for the same
grating but now drifting in the opposite
direction and what's already very clear
from here right is that the f1
modulation is much more pronounced when
the stimulus drift in one direction a
super 2 under stimulus drift in the
other one and in fact the reason are a
very good
correlation between the amplitude of the
f1 modulation of the thalamic input with
the amplitude of the f1 modulation of
the membrane potential as shown here on
the other hand if we look at the
integral of the current right the so
called charge the integral of that
current in time during the period of
visual stimulation what you observe is
that this charge is the same no matter
what the direction of the stimulus is
right so what is discharge he started
proportional to the amount of glutamate
that has been released from the thalamus
onto this new world so the amount of
glutamate that has been released from
the thalamus on to this neuron is the
same no matter what the direction of the
stimulus is whether drifting to the
right or whether drifting to the left
right it's only the temporal
distribution of this release of
glutamate on the neuron that changes
depending on the direction of the
stimulus if the stimulus drifts to the
right you have those big bouts right of
excitation as shown here by this f1
modulation if on the other hand the
stimulus drift to the left the
excitation is weaker but more
homogeneously distributed in time okay
so the charge is essentially
non-correlated or very weakly correlated
right with the direction selectivity of
the membrane potential
so the f1 amplitude modulation of atomic
excitation is directionally selective
how is directions selectivity of dynamic
excitation generator right and so
dynamic excitation must summate in time
more efficiently since it's the same
amount of time with excitation that you
release on to that you that your neuron
receives no matter whether whether the
stimulus drift to the right or to the
left but in one case as it produces
those very big peaks and valleys right
dynamic excitation must submit in time
more efficiently in one direction as
compared to the other does the time
course of dynamic excitation must depend
on the special phase of the stimulus and
so to address this question was too
needy there is a very cute experiment he
started first with drifting grating
while recording in the whole circle
figuration from a layer for neuron white
single cortex and established which one
was the preferred orientation and
direction of the stimulus based on this
f1 modulation and clearly you can see
here that in response to all those
gratings right the preferred one is a
horizontal grating drifting downward
right is the one that produces the
strongest f1 motivation so now you took
this horizontal grating and presented
stating gratings right
essentially steel frames of the movie of
a grating drifting down to their steel
frames right and so this is one of the
steel frame and if you present that
steel frame for 250 milliseconds you'd
get this dynamic excitation then you can
present the next steel frame right it's
just a little bit phase up right and
here you see that produces slightly
larger thalamic excitation and so on and
you can present them essentially the 20
frames that make up a full cycle or 22
frames here I'm showing just a few right
and what you observe first of all is
that some phases of the grating produces
a larger current as compared to other
phases of the grating and this is
consistent with what I told you before
namely that the thesis of the grating in
wind the black bar matches the peak of
the off receptive field and the white
bar matches the peak of the on receptive
field and so you get a large atomic
excitation while in other cases is not
the case but there is something you know
for other phases it's not the case but
there is something more important than
this you see that there are some phases
right that produce fast dynamic
excitation and some phases that produce
dynamic excitation that the case very
slowly alright and so if you see this
response to static grating one intuition
would be well maybe in order to
maximally sum this excitation right you
want the phases that produce a slow
Ptolemaic excite-ation
to proceed the phases that produce a
fast dynamic excitation because first
you have a phase that produce smooth
ceramic excitation and then that phase
that produce fast dynamic excitation
fast anemic excitation is going to be
able to ride on the not yet
completely decades tale of the slow
Ptolemaic excitation well in the other
direction that's not going to be
possible first you have a face that
reduce faster lamech excitation and then
the one that comes with no dynamic
excitation when when the face for
scooter amic excitation is going to
appear faster lamech excitation which
already have completely BK and so we can
we can clearly very simply test this by
taking to various traces staggering they
mean time as if the grating was moving
right and see how this song and so now
here is an example for four identical
cycle we take that little current here
and we repeat it four time then the next
current repeated four time and they are
staggered in time to mimic right a
drifting rating you take all of those
current together here you see the slow
one that precedes the fast one right you
sum them simply a simple sum of the
grating and you see this very nice f1
modulation now if you take exactly the
same currents right but some them in the
opposite direction such that the faster
and proceed that the slow current right
you see that the f1 modulation is
strongly reduced right and in fact there
is a very nice correlation right between
the sound great direction selectivity
index of the responses to static grating
and the direction selectivity index of
the same you run in response to two
static gratings another way to
illustrate the change in in the decay
time constant of those dynamic
excitation according to the phase of the
stimulus in through this special
temporal plot here on the x axis you
have time on the on the y axis you have
the special phase of the static grating
that was presented in the heat map is
simply the amplitude of the current
right so you see here for example that
around 225 degrees here you have a
current that Peaks very early but also
the case very early because you go very
quickly into a cold color on the other
hand if you look at a special phase
which is at 135 around here you have
made me less of a peak
but you have a current at last for much
longer right so this is a special type
or a receptive field of this neuron
mapped with grating of different phases
and if you look you can you can look at
that at four four five different time
bins right at the center of gravity if
you want for those five time being aware
of where the current is and you see that
it's not there is a there is a
essentially an asymmetry right and this
asymmetry say predicts the direction
selectivity of this neon this case from
phases from slow phases to fast phases
and this is a this is for all Direction
selective neuron right so so what's
important here is that the response to
whom just I think the response to two
static grating present at a different
phases predicts that the direction
selectivity of the neuron yes this is
the second part of my talk give me a
moment right so freezer sleeping slow
excitation proceed phases a little fast
excitation for optimism nation and this
determined the preferred direction what
the term is the time course of of of
dynamic excitation very good all right
and so I'm going to first propose that
it's the duration of of firing of
dynamic neurons right that there are
some talented neuron that in response to
a given stimulus with a given special
phase far along for a long time
producing a slow decaying thalamic
excitation while there other Ptolemaic
neuron which looks somewhere slightly
off that far for a more brisk as amount
of time producing faster Tellem in
became but in order to test this
hypothesis we need to make paired
recording we need to record from a
cortical neuron right and we need to
simultaneously record from coastal
animal that impinge on that cortical
neuron to see how they fire in response
to the various phases of the stimulus
okay so with the holster recording in
the neuron we are going to have the
thalamic excitation and we're going to
know whether the dynamic excitation is
fast or slow in response to the various
stimuli
and by recording in the pre-synaptic
dynamic neuron to that particular
cortical neuron we are good to know what
is the firing pattern of those of those
neurons so here's a cool example from
from from this series of experiment from
from Tony this is a layer for neuron is
clearly directionally selective you see
it it responds very very nice in two
toes
horizontal vertical grating and drifting
to the right but not to the left right
and for that particular neuron Tony was
lucky enough to record from two
Ptolemaic neurons presynaptic to it
right and the reason why we know there
are pristine optic is that if you align
the spike either spontaneous of visually
occurring spike of this unit one right
to recording of this cortical neuron
during cortical silencing in voltage
clamp you see a very nice excitatory
postsynaptic current it is also called
unitary postsynaptic current Louise
another unit that he could isolate right
and this other unit also produces in
response to spike - you need to a
spontaneously or visually works like a
nice excitatory excitatory current so
now we have for this particular neuron
this particular cortical nerve we have
two units in the DL GN that's directly
in pins on it let's see how they respond
to the various phases of vertical
grating and so this is an example of a
phase of a steady grating that produces
a relatively fast dynamic excitation and
this is in the same neuron right another
phase of the static rating that in
contrast producers are relatively slow
dynamic excitation when you present this
phase of the static grating you see that
unit one this is the two in blue is the
pre-stimulus time histogram of unit one
in response to this phase of the grating
this the unit one fires very briskly
right for the first 20 30 millisecond
and then stopped firing well you need to
essentially doesn't fire at all right in
response to the parents of this data
grating if you should this slightly
different phase of the state in grading
on the offset by maybe 50 or 60 degrees
now the situation is very
you need one keep firing right maybe a
little bit less still very briefly at
the onset of the stimulus and inter stop
firing but you need to now fari far as
very much right and first in a prolonged
manner consistent with the fact that the
tannic excitation that we were recording
from that neuron had a much longer decay
right so this particular experiment is
suggestive of the possibility that
ceramic excitation in response to
different phases has different decays
because the thalamic neurons in the dgn
might fire either briskly or in a
prolonged manner depending on the phase
of of the stimulus but yes the cell is
more transient in fact we didn't see we
with regard to the onset we can discuss
it later in this case beyond that seems
to be a bit later but but the real
difference right is a transient versus a
sustained response right okay so we this
is one of the few examples in which we
managed to get in which Tony managed to
get to new role in pink ink on the same
cortical neuron most of the 20 pairs
that Tony got during during this series
of recording were one Ptolemaic neuron
in one presynaptic dynamic neuron to a
cortical neuron and into to analyze this
statistically what we did is we did heat
maps of the duration of tannic
excitation to the various phases those
are the same Ptolemaic excitation I
showed you before right here is a the
fees that produces slow excitation is
the phase of plastic citation and then
we compare them right with the heat map
of the presynaptic neuron here you have
a presynaptic neuron that he has a
sustained response right and you can see
this and this heat map and it's a
transient response you can do this for
every phase of the stimulus for all 20
pairs at Tony recorded rate and what
Tony beat here he ordered from a fast
stomach responses to slow Ptolemaic
responses those are seen
ordered across those 20 pairs for all
the stimulus phases this is the summary
photo experiment ordered according to
duration and then for every one of those
phases he can look at the very stimulus
time histogram that the duration of
firing of the presynaptic Ptolemaic
neuron and indeed what you can see is
that although this region is clearly
under sampled because we have only only
about 20 pairs clearly phases of the
stimulus that produce fast olymic
excitation are generally accompanied by
pre synaptic firing in the drgr neuron
that is more brisk more transient right
you see the firing occurs here and much
less here on the other hand feeders of
stimulated Pradeep reproduce prolong
dynamic excitation right are accompanied
by firing of Ptolemaic nuan that is a
much more sustained as shown by this
upper part right another thing that I'm
we're not going to show you here but
that it's important is dynamic neural
not either transient or sustained right
you never we never had we never
countered a situation in which a neuron
could fire in a transient manner to a
given phase of the stimulus and then in
a sustained manner to another phase of
the stimulus so you have either
transient stomach neuron right those
ones and they only respond to certain
features of the stimulus and when they
respond the respond in transit manner
and then you have sustained that new run
right that only respond to other phases
of the of the stimulus and but when they
responded to stay they respond in a
sustained manner so transient sustained
Ptolemaic firing matches the time course
of dynamic excitation so we can indeed
compare right the special temporal
receptive field of Telemachus citation
right for this particular neuron with
the spatial temporal receptive field
that we would get if we were to but by
by by combining
the firing of of those two of those two
unit so this is the fact the special
temporary septa fielder for the firing
of unit one as you can see it doesn't
really respond to all phases right it
responds very transiently here and it
respond to those faded from between
about maybe eighty degrees to two
hundred and ninety but not two toes one
and this is the special temporary septic
field of unit - it only responds to
those phases in a very sustained manner
if you combine it you clear have this a
symmetric special temporary septic field
and this asymmetry matches quite well
the asymmetry of dynamic excitation that
we observed in this name in that
particular neuron so as as a model right
we have different special position of a
visual stimulus activity' lamech neuron
with distinct response properties either
transient so sustained leading to faster
fluid secretion in cortical neuron and
this can be modeled very very simply
imagine you have a transient neuron rat
that look at a given portion of of the
visual field and responds very briefly
and by responding very briefly produces
let's say an excitatory current in the
target cortical neuron that decays with
a time concept of 50 millisecond dinah
you have a sustained neuron that
sustained your looks at slightly offset
position in space right and it has a
more sustained firing such that when it
fires in response with stimulation it
produces an excitatory current in
Direction selective neuron that decays
with a time constant under 75
millisecond this is our modeled response
to the various phases of the grating of
our transient neuron you see it has this
f1 modulation and it peaks at 225
degrees right and it has this special
temporal receptive field this is the
response of our sustained neuron right
it also is modulated by by by the
periodicity of the grating but very
importantly its peak is offset in this
case for this model it's offset by 90
degrees right and so the sum right which
is what is observed by the directionally
selective neuron
to inputs right which are per se not
directionally selective is this one
right it's an excitatory postsynaptic
current who has a fast component and the
flow component of the case but the
relative contribution of the slow
component of the fast component depends
on the phase of of the grating right and
by depending on the phase of the grating
it has an isometric special temporary
septa field and in fact if you sum two
stimuli to the responses in one
direction or the other in one case you
have a very nice f1 modulation in the
other direction a very and so this
essentially eliminates model-free as a
major contributor of direction
selectivity clearly Direction
selectivity is not inherited from the
retina it eliminates model 1 as a major
contributor for the de novo generation
of Direction selectivity in the cortex
but it highlights model 2 namely the
direction selectivity occurs at the
convergence of Ptolemaic in would be
different spatial and temporal response
processes right and so very quickly I
would like to then how many neurons
actually contribute to the visual
response of cortical how many telemakian
contribute to the visual response of a
cortical neurons
since we have pairs and we have the
amplitude of a unitary PC we can convert
the EPS see the unitary PSB PSC with the
firing rate of the tolima Quran in
response to a drifting grating this is
the prettiest Emil's time histogram of
this neuron this is dynamic excitation
generated by this new by this dynamic
neuron which is by made by convolving
this very stable time histogram with the
unitary PSC this is the actual response
of the cortical neuron to the drifting
rating and so you can see that this
particular deal genuine contributed a
little bit of the total current and so
you can look in general how much does it
contribute every dynamic neuron
contribute on average one point 25
percent of the time in current and so on
average you have approximately 18 the
LGN neuron that converge on to occur
to generate a really good response so in
conclusion Direction selectivity is
computed de novo in layer four of mass
primary visual cortex right it's not
inherited from the regular layer for
neuron extract motion direction by
campaign combining Ptolemaic inputs that
are offset in space ending time namely
transient and sustained thalamic neurons
that look a slightly offset position in
visual space and approximately eighty
Ptolemaic neuron contribute to the
response and this was the work of two
million thank you two questions did you
compare the time constants of the
unitary epsps from the transient neurons
to the sustained neurons release yeah
yeah they're very similar yeah and then
and you also understand maybe like at
the speed if you change the grading
speed yes you can so essentially based
on the response of dynamic the
Deuteronomic response to static gratings
right you can predict what the temporal
frequency tuning is of that cell now we
can predict it but we didn't test it and
the reason is that the experiment are
quite long right and so we we didn't
have enough time to also explore the
parameter space of temporal frequency so
our prediction have remained untested
but clearly we can yes these are
sustained entrench themselves that they
correspond to like parvo and Magno or
different III don't know I don't know
whether in the mouth those are
corresponding to manland parvo I'm not
sure if any of any data that would
indicate this I guess is it a well-known
distinction that already exists there
like there's already know this or so so
so clearly it is it is it is there they
have been quite well characterized even
by a recent study by Pisco Patel in the
mouth of transient cell to sustain so
now how bimodal II they are really
distributed or whether it's a continuum
that's that's a matter of the bay but
yes
there is there is clearly a wide
spectrum of response dynamics that have
been well characterized in the master
host yes so I do recorded from a lair
for yourself that is not the orientation
facility and that's not Direction
selective
so yes we've recruited from men you've
met if I'm the majority for recordings a
hunk shot are from cortical neuron that
we define as a known direction that is
selective so there is a threshold for
directions selectivity below the
threshold we decide that is not
directionally sorry if and so what
happens in two selves is not that they
don't receive input from either the
transient or the sustain they both
receive input from the trends of the
sustained however the the spatial
separation doesn't exist essentially the
contribution of the fast and slow in the
slow component in the Tomic excitation
is the same at every phase of the
stimulus yes so one of your other
concerns
transient response in a much bigger peak
so that the area under the transient
response was sort of equivalent to what
you sold under the sustain but it didn't
look like that was represented right
looks like the peak the transactions and
the sustained responses are probably
saying yeah about yes I'm not sure which
cartoon you are referring to though what
is there a cartoon yes now the idea I
want to imply that slice and once very
key no no no so in in the cat there was
a lot of work on this idea but involving
what they call flags so we thought
whether whether whether we could so
first of all lag the cell son as defined
in the kata and also in the monkey have
a very very precise definition not that
they have some delayed onset today
they've been parameterize quite well and
so if we take those very strict
definitions then I would say there is
not something like that in the mouse
however if you look at the other heat
map of the very stimuli time histogram
well I I know I don't have it I don't
have it here anyhow there is a there are
some cells that have indeed that are
sustained and have indeed a delayed
onset and so at least qualitatively they
might resemble black cells we have maybe
10% of those
any examples were a cell with Direction
selective when you when the phone cortex
was active but the caning Direction
selective with silence okay yeah so we
had that and we even had the new version
of so that it was directionally
selective when the cortex in one
direction when the cortex in current
clamp or the cortex was active and then
with silence we look at the dynamic
input and not only its it's still
Direction selective but in the opposite
direction so there are minority of cells
but there are two cells that in fact
prevent us for having this group a very
precise correlation at the beginning
there is some noise and so our
interpretation to this is that as I was
saying cortical neuron receive a layer
four neuron receive a lot of excitation
in fact the majority of excitation from
other layer four cortical neuron in a
previous study from Anthony we've seen
that there is a good correlation between
the tuning property of the t'lani
input and the tuning property of the of
the cortical input right so if the
dynamic input has a given orientation
selectivity and a given Direction
selectivity cortical excitation with
stained to match that excitation meaning
that like to like excited shudder but
this is not an absolute rule so there
are there situation probably in which
the overall response of the layer for
neuron is in one direction because it
receives that direction and information
from other cortical neuron and since the
majority of excitation is going to
respond like this but the talus is
actually telling it to do the opposite
does this answer your question
well one of you I'm asking the same
question every year in Kerala pretty
clearly school the role of recurrent
connections shape oh no not at all not
at all but in fact what what this what
what is data about are not about all the
mechanisms that contribute to Direction
selectivity right there is clearly in
emissions by fraction a number of
non-linearity here was what is the
mechanism in which the first seed for
Direction selectivity is plant and in
the cortex right you don't need any
direction selectivity for from each
individual thalamic neurons right to
create direction selectivity in the
cortex you just need the special
temporal ah offset essentially once you
have that special temporal off that I'm
sure that recurrent connections spike
threshold inhibition are going to play a
major role in sharpening and amplifying
it possibly presumably the ones that you
recorded from Vermont to actually snow
they are they are so now I think that's
how we good I have an answer for that
so some of our neurons from offer in our
pairs we had a Tara McDonald but were
indeed directionally selective there is
a description depending on where you put
your your thresh on that 10 to 15
percent of neurons in the core of of the
thalamus are the hub directional
selectivity but there is absolutely no
correlation between the direction
selectivity of the tally McNew on and
the directions are activity of its pulse
in Africa and directional selective
cortical neurons wiped out it's
essentially wiped out yes it's averaged
out I would say through those 80
convergences
I don't know think you know the
receptacles are ready to change at all
between anesthetize an anesthetized how
do the receptive field change
so so yes there are actually interests
in the receptive field right now I so
the the surround suppression is is
different so the size of the receptive
field might be a little bit larger I
[Music]
don't think that the changes that leave
the changes are aware of that occur
through anesthesia that tools would
affect would have a major effect on on
this basic map
this is the answer to another question
is the directions like to be highly
temporally frequency tune that matches
up exactly the time constants of the
slow fast so these neurons are not just
like they're very fast or very slow city
so so as I said we we can predict their
temporal frequency tuning but we haven't
tested yeah well you know if you look at
if you look at playing the mouse
literature there is there is essentially
no database with regard to that would
allow you to make a prediction based on
how we search for it but it's there is
there is not a very good database for
you it really is only sense a certain
set of speeds
well behaviorally yes but whether this
has to do with cortex of a super or
cornichons a very hard question
so in Salamis you have some distribution
of these you know fast and then slower
responses as a function of phase and you
can presumably no one characterized that
distribution and I guess my question is
is the distribution of Direction
selectivity in the downstream in the
cortex consistent with a random
projection of these fast and slow so
whether if you were to take a random
group of 18 you run and hook the map
whether you would get less well so so I
we haven't texted that so I don't know
there is a maybe maybe you start with
just the random combination of two or
three and toes could give you an initial
bias and then through heavy and rule at
the 80s I so intuitively although we
never tested I I guess that if we will
just take a bunch of 80 neuron that kind
of look more or less then I think it
would flatten down I have a hard time
believing that you would have first is
very nice a fun modulation and that you
could be active and that's very sharp
direction
it has to be feed-forward plus some I
would say so yeah all right so in fact
that's a question to you so so so so you
so the first the first thing is this so
you with this you're implying right that
sustained and transient in something
that is purely inherited from the retina
right in the face is correct
yeah no no yes I remember that
yes no no that's true yes I would say I
would say that if you you would lose
both direction and orientation
selectivity yes absolutely could then
okay yeah sure I think I think so I
think so could you still have Direction
selectivity with two off cells one that
was transient one that was sustained if
they happen to be specially offset there
are no transient off cells in the mouth
there is a you have you have sustained
down sustained off and sustained there's
a second so there is out of the four
combination there is one which is
missing in the mouth so okay very good
so so for orientation selectivity you
need on and off for direction you could
have a two-on-one transient one
sustained that are that are that are
that are just especially offset and you
would get it that's true even a better
answer
okay let's thank mastermind
[Applause]